la unión europea' endurece su postura
sobre china y myanmar los ministros de
relaciones exteriores del bloque
comunitario sancionaron a cuatro
funcionarios y a una empresa china
ellos están señalados de haber
contribuido a los supuestos abusos
contra la minoría musulmana de los uigur
es el alto representante de la unión
europea josep borrell explicó por que
sancionan a los dirigentes de la región
autónoma de xinjiang donde viven los
seguros
cuatro personas y una entidad de china
por uso sistemático de trabajo forzoso
detenciones arbitrarias y violaciones de
la libertad de religión y creencias de
uigures en xinjiang los sancionados no
podrán entrar a ninguno de los 27 países
del bloque y cualquier bien o activo que
tengan allí será congelado es la primera
vez que europa sanciona a china desde la
masacre de tiananmen en 1989 la
retaliación china sancionó a cuatro
instituciones del viejo continente y a
diez funcionarios incluyendo cinco
europarlamentarios el gigante asiático
instó a la unión europea a no
entrometerse en sus asuntos internos
esta medida basada únicamente en
mentiras y desinformación ignora y
distorsiona los hechos e interfiere
gravemente en los asuntos de china viola
flagrantemente el derecho internacional
y las normas básicas que rigen las
relaciones internacionales y socava
gravemente las relaciones entre china y
la unión europea por otro lado la unión
europea también sancionó al jefe de la
junta militar de mianmar min aung lines
por la represión que se ha desatado en
las calles al menos 250 manifestantes
prodemocracia han muerto en los choques
con la policía y más de 2.600 personas
han sido detenidos incluyendo 40
periodistas la sanción es la
determinación más contundente que ha
tomado la unión europea frente a las
situaciones ni al mar